i mean i've said this look men can have  sex with a hole in the wall i don't know  who's on the other side  and be fine  so i get you when you say that men can  see sex as animalistic  um but in relationships is is that the  same is that the same case  well not my relationship right okay some  relationships  and uh maybe  maybe the guys can can confirm or not  but i guess that there will be some  times or some occasions where the sex  with your partner  may not be about intimacy it may not be  about connecting with you right now it  might be i've had a very stressful week  and i just need a release  i might not be thinking about your  pleasure um